我是他妈要转变思路啊，
她愿意心疼你，
她愿意照顾你，
她愿意打扮你，
她愿意给你花钱，
你就像一个妹妹一样接纳就行了啊，
我想咨询一下情感问题啊，
能不能问我，
然后我再想好呀，
那你现在是呃，
两个人谈恋爱的状态呢，
还是结了婚的状态呢？
谈恋爱那后我现在是27岁，
谈了多久呀？
两个月怎么吧，
两个月男方是干什么的？
你俩是怎么认识的，
是相亲啊还是朋友介绍呀，
还是怎么认识的？
他是干销售的，
因为我之前我谈恋爱的了，
然后其实关注你好久，
我就是用小号恋的你，
就是我跟他恋爱的时候，
我听你的那些小视频就很清醒，
但是我一谈恋爱我就废了，
这男的长得帅吗？
有点帅吗？
个子高吗？
高，
他一米9，
我一米七，
你俩已经发发生关系了是吗？
嗯，
对，
才刚开始的时候，
上头都比较容易，
她是我妹介绍的，
你妹介绍的，
因为我其实我都想以后不结婚了，
就很悲观，
我那时候就因为我这个人就是你说的那种内何不太稳定，
就很喜欢，
就让都陪着我，
我就突然就很着急想找对象，
我妹就给我介绍了他一个朋友，
所以她年纪比我小，
就3岁，
小3岁，
你27，
她干什么工作的呀，
为啥呀，
给医院妹麻醉吧，
那他收入怎么样啊她。
收入好像跟他的业绩有关，
不是方他爸妈是干啥的呀？
他爸妈都是国药的哦，
都是正经工作是吧？
国药是属于国企是吧？
听好了他是国领导，
他是独资吗？
对，
他爸爸都在国药，
然后他卖给医院是吧？
我家这姊女有关系啊，
对，
所以他们家其实条件还可以，
那你这头呢？
你这头是兄弟姊妹几个呀，
我有一个妹妹，
爸妈是干啥的呀？
我妈现在退休了，
我爸其实也失业了吧，
失业一两年，
但是我爸那前她就一直炒股，
她比较聪明，
然后就赚了点钱，
然后我们家还有几套房子会有租金，
那你们家的资产是千万级别的还是百万级别的呀？
有百万级别的，
因为我们这是小地方，
房子收租金大概一个月能收多少钱呀，
我也不太清楚啊，
那你自己是什么学历呀，
我是本科，
自己找了个什么工作呀，
也是当地的一个国企，
那你这条件不是嘎嘎好啊，
又1米7，
身高那么高，
那就去呗，
也就是问题是啥，
我现在很内耗，
就是刚开始我就觉得都挺好，
就落差感非常大，
就一个月内，
他之前就是消息都会经常回复，
然后去，
然后报备拍视频，
但是现在他可能是因为工作忙就不怎么发消息，
然后等到过年的时候，
那都没有工。
过了，
但他还是不怎么回消息，
就那么一天，
我24小时联系不到这个人了，
然后又很慌张，
然后我又问了一下他身边的人，
之前了解的不太清楚，
才知道就是他之前去谈过好几段，
然后他这个人就算如果分手的话，
他也不会直接明确说我俩分手，
他就会冷暴力量，
然后就让女方默认是分手了，
我一联系不到他，
我很焦虑，
我就在想他是不是要跟我分手，
姐妹啊，
一米九的弟弟能睡多久多久吧，
我跟你说别想那么多啊，
就能睡多久睡多久，
你想他，
你找他去睡，
他他愿意跟你保证第一孕的情况下，
保证不伤害自己的情况下，
能睡多久就睡多久，
就完事儿了啊，
别想那么多，
别想那么远，
别想那么长久啊，
就他都给我洗呢，
我俩好像还没接触太久，
他就说过年要见家长，
这样过年去他家，
然后我又一想，
我想着反正我去想去他家不太好，
我也想让他来我家，
但是我一想，
但是我俩太快了，
所以说过年也没有天，
反正现在你也不给他花钱是吧，
你也别想人家给你提供什么情绪价值啊，
也别想以后别想结婚别想，
呃，
就长期啊什么的啊，
帮助自己，
帮助自己是什么意思呢？
工作好好干，
钱好好赚，
健身好好健身，
美容好好美容，
对吧？
修养自己就好好修养自己，
女的哈，
就特别容易跟人家睡觉了之后，
就一门心思扑到人家身上，
我推荐你们去看。
的电影，
这个电影你们所有人都是给我看，
这个电影名字叫做在最好的时间遇到你，
谭聪韵演那个电影都是给我看，
基本上吧，
女的一旦有后，
一个男的跟一个男的遇掉了之后，
就黏着人家，
人家就开始逃，
就开始跑，
就开始觉得没意思，
就开始觉得你什么时候回去啊，
你怎么不去学校啊，
你怎么不去读书啊？
大家就这意思，
你现在就是这个状态，
跟人家睡觉的时候就黏着人家，
恨不得到人家的时候把自己的身体都要揉进去，
不得天天黏一块儿，
男的就得跑，
反过来想，
你要自己干自己的事儿，
该爬山爬山，
该游泳游泳，
看他小吊带，
穿个小吊带，
该发朋友圈让他发朋友圈，
该跟同友聚会跟朋友聚会，
该跟同学聚会跟同学聚会，
该唱歌唱歌，
该跳舞跳舞，
该工作工作，
该休假休假，
该看电影看电影，
你不粘着他，
反而这也可能有将来，
你这么天天粘着他，
我早晚得跑。
我过一个视频情人节送给我了个2000左右的包，
但是我不说你，
我就把他说了一顿，
我说你眼光就看你看怎么怎么样，
我说让他把这给我退了，
我就来，
就是你恋爱经验太少，
怎么说呢啊，
是你多谈几个你就明白了，
他哪怕送一坨屎，
你都得说这个屎的造型好别致啊，
怎家送你个礼物了，
你还嫌人家品味差，
还让人家退你玩谁跟你谈？
那我，
我也不跟你谈呢，
你真真是的啊，
谈恋爱大家图什么不会开心图高兴是吧？
人家捧一颗真心给你，
你说是坨屎，
谁跟你？
啊，
我现在才反应过来，
当时做的不太好，
因为他那天有一天24小时没回我消息，
后来晚上就联系上之后，
他就给我转了5200，
又过了几天，
因为我老觉得我受不了东西，
不好意思，
我就又把钱退给他，
那也收了，
我会让她手机收的，
哎，
我跟你这个女的谈恋爱啊，
我跟你说啊，
挺难啊，
你应该多学学人家怎么谈恋爱，
应该学学人家怎么谈恋爱，
你吧，
可能长相没问题，
身材没问题，
家境也没问题，
工作也没问题，
就是这个谈恋爱的恋商，
谈恋爱的天分，
你就相当于富数，
你知道吗？
你都不是什么小学生，
初中生，
高中生，
大学生，
你这谈恋爱的那个电商啊，
就是属于负数，
你多学学人家对吧，
谈恋爱怎么谈，
你看这个男的还是愿意给你付出的，
又给你买2000的包，
又给你5200的，
这个转账男的是愿意给你谈的，
主要是你这个谈恋爱的技术吧，
实在需要磨练，
实在需要学习，
我教你一招好不好？
你别老想着说用这种扫别人的兴，
打击别人的方式去求他爱你，
你本质上逻辑是我扫你的信，
我打击你，
我退你的钱，
你说我想让你更多的关注我，
更多的来爱我，
你怎么不给我打电话呀？
你怎么不给我回消息啊？
你怎么不主动找我呀？
都是我们女人。
别低位的一种表现，
我们现在意识到我的问题了，
不要老想着你什么不给我打电话，
你为什么不找我？
首先你自己一定要把所有的注意力先放在自己的身上，
每天把自己的时间安排的满一点，
刻意的去见同学，
见朋友，
刻意的去找项目干，
刻意的去具体的去让自己动起来，
是吧，
学着唱歌，
学个跳舞，
不仅又有工作，
然后呢，
跟别人相处的时候，
可以大胆的表达，
我觉得你身材好，
我觉得你屁股翘，
我觉得你腿直，
我觉得你腰特别有力，
可以只求说说具体的事儿，
而且我现在就有点想结婚，
就有可能有点着急，
妈呀，
越越着急越不行，
但他这个人他很喜欢跟我承诺一个开玩笑，
我说那你去我吧，
他就说啊，
那就唯一的时候啊，
我先去你家，
去完你家再去我家，
然后我们再三天再出去玩，
你一越表现很想结婚的话，
他就吓跑了，
因为他其实他跟你相处是很累的，
明白有可能他本身人家这个人也善良，
也愿意跟你付出，
就是跟你相处累，
你越着急越吓跑，
你可以非常坦诚的告诉他你一招啊，
姐教那一招啊，
今天你就说，
你别看我说比你大几岁，
但是我谈恋爱的经验几乎没有，
所以有的时候你跟我相处的时候会觉得很累，
如果你跟我相处的时候觉得我作，
觉得我累，
你要告诉我，
就是让他觉得他在恋爱的关系。
当成他是哥哥，
你是妹妹，
他得带着你，
他得哄着你，
他得教你，
你要承认这一点啊，
发自内心的承认这一点，
让他有成就感，
让他像个教练一样，
像个老师一样带着你谈恋爱，
因为他说他就是很喜欢，
他比较喜欢给女的付出，
然后花钱，
他喜欢把女生打扮的漂漂亮亮的，
看你要接纳，
你要学会接纳，
就是在你们的关系当中的角色扮演，
你就扮演那个小妹妹，
跟着她吃，
跟着她喝，
跟着她玩儿，
跟她学习怎么谈恋爱，
那你不难考，
她前几天其实业绩不太好，
有可能也比较心疼她那种花钱的，
你又不是她妈，
要转变思路啊，
她愿意心疼你，
她愿意照顾你，
她愿意打扮你，
她愿意给你花钱，
你就像一个妹妹一样接纳就行了啊，
好，
那就这样不行了，
我要再给你们传授一点经验的话，
到时候你们又要在外面去造谣了，
说龙飞姐你到底是谈了多少个男朋友才能谈出这些经验的，
有多少个恋爱宝典才能谈成这样的？
龙菲姐你可以犀利一点，
有的人他需要直接灵魂的话点醒他，
你这样会有疏离感，
怎么点醒呢？
很多东西它就是自己要一点一点去试，
就像那个水温，
你得一点一点去试那个水温，
你才知道你洗澡适合什么样的水温，
它不是说一下子就你把它就变成一个人换一个人很。
谈的他们两个人之间的相处的话，
我觉得问题其实是出在女孩子身上，
最大的问题就是他不会谈恋爱，
他没有经验，
他在恋爱的这个赛道上的话，
他就纯属小白，
他是用那种批评男生，
指责男生的方式，
其实他求的是想让男生多爱我一点，
多关心我一点，
但是你用的方法却是把他越推越远，
是这么个情况啊，
记得点赞关注。